[Music]
galaxy size celebration they also call
that a Star Wars the last Jedi premiere
but as Carly still found out one of its
stars almost didn't make it
[Music]
crazy amazing just lots of exciting
people every which way you turn I was
really nervous like an hour ago
and then I got here Daisy wore dark blue
and white sequin dress adorned with
stars by Monse and everyone was on the
lookout for John boyega he nearly missed
the premiere after getting stranded in
Atlanta due to bad weather I was in that
Lobby just like guys you need to get me
light I need to find the way I consider
driving could potentially miss the
biggest premiere the cast was excited to
get to hold one very special Star Wars
prop do you like our lightsaber Mike
flag and much as my dress do I speak
into this and two fans you may recognize
post questions to the cast alright so
here's what I want to know what's the
craziest thing a fan has ever asked you
to do craziest I can't but I said no
rest assured I said no sign a body part
it's just like sign my belly no I'm fine
thank you
so who's the better stormtrooper Prince
William or Prince Harry well they're the
both the dark side so I don't know
maybe Prince Harry because you know he
does have a little more of like a
rebellious streak in there both princes
are expected at tomorrow's premiere in
London mark got a Jedi lesson on royal
red carpet etiquette when you talk to
the royal family you're not allowed to
say anything that would require a
response if Princess Margaret says she
liked the film you say thank you ma'am
don't say what was your favorite part
opens this Friday
look at this fans have already started
camping outside the Chinese Theater
here in Hollywood
you